The School of Life has branches all around
the world but till now, it hasn’t been directly
involved in the US.
But now we’re coming, with a big 3 day conference
that we’re going to be running in San Francisco,
starting on the 23rd of March, 2018.
Taking place in the beautiful Yerba Buena
center right in the heart of San Francisco,
this is a three day event about everything
we care about at the School of Life: emotional
intelligence, wisdom, self-understanding,
love, friendship and meaning.
The conference will mirror what happened in
our first conference in Lisbon Portugal in
October 2017. That means we’ll have lectures
in the day, great meals together, the best
kinds of interactions, and chats about everything
that matters late into the night. It’ll
be a true chance to experience a globally-minded
community dedicated to learning, kindness,
self-exploration and wisdom.
The conference lasts three days and is led
by our founder and creative lead, Alain de
Botton - and will feature our best teachers,
and our very best, and most transformative
ideas.
If you’re interested in coming to San Francisco
to meet us at the end of March, please click
on the link on the screen now.
You’ll learn a lot - return with a huge
number of useful new ideas and make friends
for life.
We hope to see you there.